Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do: Dr. Bright is not allowed to "accidentally"
spill green gelatin on a dead body.
It is well known by SCP staff, particularly
those in the O5 council, that allowing SCP-447's
green slime to come into contact with a dead
body will result in disaster on a catastrophic
scale.
Of course, Dr. Bright decided that it would
be hilarious to procure some lime jello from
the canteen, pretend to trip and fall, and
spill the gelatin all over a body being observed
by the O5.
Admittedly, the first time, it was a bit funny.
But it was also extremely stressful, multiple
staff fainted, and O5-2 made it a point to
tell Dr. Bright that he "owed him a new pair
of khakis" after the sudden terror had made
him, well, ruin his.